انسحب الاحتلال من جامعه النجاح الوطنيه
بعد عمليه عسكريه استمرت ساعه تم خلالها
اعتقال 25 طالبا من داخل اروقه الجامعه
فيما اعتدى الاحتلال على رجلين من امن
الجامعه ما ادى لنقلهم الى المستشفى ما
جرى خلال ساعات الفجر قوات الاحتلال
وعشرات الاليات العسكريه اقتحمت الجامعه
من المنطقه الغربيه وصولا الى كليات
الجامعه حيث فرض حصارا واسعا داخل اروقه
الجامعه تم خلال لها اعتقال كافه الطلبه
المتواجدين في داخل الجامعه كان مجلس
اتحاد الطلبه برئاسه الكتله الاسلاميه قد
دعا الى اعتصام للمطالبه من قبل اداره
الجامعه
بتقسيط الفصل الدراسي ليتسنى لعموم الطلبه
التسجيل في ظل الوضع الاقتصادي القائم في
الضفه الغربيه وحمل مجلس الطلبه اداره
الجامعه المسؤوليه الكامله عما جرى خلال
ساعات الليل داخل اروقه الجامعه لمماطلة
الاوضاع في الاراضي
الفلسطينيه من جامعه النجاح ليث
جعار
الجزيره